well europe has become the epicenter of
the covet 19 pandemic once again here in
germany there were 45 000 new infections
on saturday alone hovering near the
highest daily level since the pandemic
began
chancellor angela merkel released a rare
video message to the nation urging
unvaccinated people to get the jab
yes
now the vaccine is here and all we have
to do is grab it grab it fast i beg you
join in and try to convince relatives
and friends too
if we stand together if we think about
protecting ourselves and caring for
others we can save our country a lot
this winter
well dw reporter michelle stockman has
been following the story for us and
she's here with me in the studio for
more on this
michelle it's uh it's a serious problem
that you cannot trust vaccination
certificates when people hand them over
just how widespread is this problem it's
a global problem law enforcement around
the world have noticed that cases of
these false vaccine certificates are
popping up if we take it to a really
local level here in berlin the berlin
division of the state police is
investigating as of this month 169 cases
of false vaccine
certificates and they're coming to their
attention through pharmacists who are
looking through the documents that
people are handing in to get those
digital certificates noticing
irregularities also doctors are saying
they're noticing their name is on
certificates when they didn't give the
jab and so it's it's really concerning
something
is happening here that law enforcement
really wants to crack down on
and they've noticed it's happening for
months ever since the additional
certificates started being handed out
and people wanted to have easier access
to public venues
okay so you say 169 in a city of more
than 3 million like berlin it you know
it doesn't seem like a lot but maybe
still those are the ones that were
caught but how easy is it to get this
kind of fake vaccination certificate
it is so easy uh just today i went on to
telegram which is a popular messaging
app
looking for these advertisements and all
they did was type in vaccination and up
pop two groups one of them had like 200
000 members and it said
order away this uh you can get either
you know the the physical copy or even a
qr code uh and they cost anywhere from
150 to 350 euros
so easy cheap but why why are people
resorting to this why do they think it's
worth it
you know
germany has not mandated the covid19
vaccine but life is shrinking for people
who are unvaccinated right now we have a
nationwide 3g rule that means in certain
public venues you can't go in unless
you're vaccinated recovered or tested
and certain restaurant tours and
event organizers can institute a 2g rule
which means you can't get in unless
you're vaccinated or recovered so if
you've decided for whatever reason not
to get a vaccinated and you want to go
place that has a 2g rule you can't get
in there and so some people rather than
be honest they want to find a workaround
um but you know the case numbers are
going up here we're seeing um here in
berlin they're looking at expanding the
2g rule and in austria tomorrow they're
expected to institute
a
lockdown of the unvaccinated which means
people
can't leave their homes except for
essential reasons if they don't have the
job so it'll be interesting to look in
the weeks ahead what happens as case
numbers rise dw's michelle stockman on
the story for us thanks so much
well one of germany's neighbors the
netherlands is also seeing a surge in
coronavirus cases the government has
responded by imposing a partial lockdown
for the next three weeks bars
restaurants and shops will have to close
early authorities are also calling on
people to limit their social contacts
the netherlands is the first country in
western europe to take this step one
that has coincided with the start of the
holiday season well now to some other
developments in the coronavirus pandemic
austria could approve a lockdown for
only people unvaccinated against covet
19. the government will meet later today
to discuss the measure
russia has reported a new daily record
number of coronavirus deaths over 1200
deaths were registered
and vietnam has welcomed its first
international tourists in almost 20
months after it closed its border to
contain the coronavirus two charter
flights brought more than 400 fully
vaccinated visitors from japan and south
korea